Trey, how you doing? Hey, doing good,
man. How are you? Pretty good. Thank you
for coming. Yeah, thanks for having me
on.
Um so, I know the subject of the
discussion is Jesus is God Almighty,
prove me wrong.
So, what I wanted to do was present you
with a syllogism that I've constructed.
And it the basically the point of the
syllogism is not to tell you that the
conclusion necessarily must follow. What
I What I want to do is ask you, okay, so
if you affirm these five premises, how
would you, given your affirmation of
Jesus being Yahweh, avoid such
conclusions? So, with that being said,
do you mind if I actually share my
screen? I've got it written out so that
we can both reference it.
Sure.
All right, cool. Let me pull it up here.
Here we go.
All right, can you see that?
Yeah, hold on.
All right.
All right. So, the first premise is that
Yahweh is the most high God. Now, as you
can see there, I've provided references
where this is explicitly stated in the
scriptures. I doubt that we disagree
about this. Is that correct? That's
correct. Right. Number two, Jesus is the
son of the most high God. Again,
explicit biblical statements. We're not
going to disagree about this, right?
Correct. Right. So, what follows from
that is that Jesus is the son of Yahweh,
of course. And what follows from that is
that Yahweh is the father of Jesus. Now,
if you then suppose, as I understand you
to do, and correct me if I'm wrong, that
Jesus is Yahweh, is that Is that right?
You affirm that? Yeah, Jesus is Yahweh.
Okay, so here's what it seems to me to
follow then from those affirmations. It
seems to follow from three and five,
Jesus being the son of Yahweh and Jesus
being Yahweh, that Jesus is the the son
of Jesus. And it follows from the
affirmation that Jesus Excuse me, that
Yahweh is the father of Jesus and four,
and that Jesus is Yahweh, that therefore
Jesus is the father of Jesus. So, what I
would ask you is, given those biblical
premises in one and two, the
straightforward derivations in three and
four, and your supposition that Jesus is
Yahweh,
do you just accept six and seven, or do
you deny them? What or yeah, basically,
do you accept them? If you deny them,
how do you deny them?
Yeah, so Yahweh is not just the father.
Yahweh is also the son. Yahweh is also
the spirit. So, Yahweh is the name of
God that is attributed to not just the
father, but the son and the spirit as
well. Can I Can I respond to that? When
you have Just really quick, when you
have passages that say that Jesus is the
son of the most high, obviously talking
about the person of the father, that's
not a negation of Jesus himself also
having the same nature as the father,
which would mean he's Yahweh as well.
Fair enough.
I'm familiar with this this way of
defining Yahweh, but that's why I went
ahead and included the following. So, if
you define Yahweh, by the way, can you
still see my screen?
Yeah. So, if you then, which I
understood you to do, say, "Look, Yahweh
isn't referring to only the father." I'm
I'm aware that you say this. So, if
Yahweh is the father, the son, and the
Holy Spirit, that doesn't seem to
actually help. It seems to make it
worse. It seems to then conclude that
Jesus is the son of the Father, Son, and
Holy Spirit from the affirmations that
Yahweh is the father of Jesus and that
Jesus is Yahweh, and also that Jesus is
the father of the Father, Son, and Holy
Spirit from the affirmation that Yahweh
is the father of Jesus and that Jesus is
Yahweh.
Yeah, no, so the reason I The problem
that you have here is that you think
that
it seems like you're using Yahweh as a
uh
is univocal term, like it's only used in
one way, and that's the problem here.
Yahweh can refer to the persons and
distinctly and individually, or it can
refer to the nature
of God.
>> Okay. So, so that's so that's why this
doesn't work. So, Jesus being Yahweh
uh, he is Yahweh by nature because he
has the same essence as the Father,
which is why he can be identified as
Yahweh, which is why he is identified as
Yahweh in scripture.
Yeah, I'm I'm aware you believe that,
but I'm honestly not hearing how you
would avoid it exactly. Let me let me
try to get it, uh, from this direction.
Um Can you still maintain my position?
Yeah, absolutely. It sounds to me like
what you're saying is that the there's a
person essence distinction. So, when you
say Jesus is Yahweh, you're you're
assigning to him possession of the
divine essence, but you're not saying
that he's his own father.
Right. So,
so you so you understand that Yahweh is
not univocal. Well, I understand that
you would you would claim that. Um, but
that's what I'm
>> Do you think that? You think that Yahweh
is univocal? I do. I think that when the
scriptures refer to Yahweh, we're
referring to a singular entity.
And I would point to you that, um
the regardless, by the way, of whether
that entity is unipersonal or
multipersonal. I want to point that out
here. I'm not assuming that Yahweh is,
um,
a unipersonal being in the syllogism.
Regardless of how many persons Yahweh
is, Yahweh is the singular God being
referred to that stands in the Father
relation to Jesus.
Okay. Do you understand? Yes, you
believe that Yahweh is a unipersonal
being.
>> No, no, hang on. I do believe that, but
I'm but my syllogism does not assume
that. It does.
Actually, it doesn't. And if you pull it
back up, you'll see again. You you said
you're you're saying that Yahweh is the
Most High God, Jesus is the son of the
Most High, therefore the Most High God,
Yahweh, is the Father of Jesus. If we're
saying Jesus is Yahweh, then we're
saying that Jesus is his own father.
That's your
That's what you're saying, right?
>> In some sense it would seem to follow.
But but I'm not Again, I'm
>> That's That's because you're using
Yahweh univocally.
Well, I'm not just using it. I'm
pointing you to the definitions in prem-
and the derivations in three and four.
That's not me just assuming this. I'm
pointing out to you and I'm asking you
how you would then respond uh or
interpret, you know, things like premise
one through four and those explicit
statements in the scripture. Because
again, if I could just point this out,
my syllogism
uh whether Yahweh is a unipersonal or a
multipersonal being. What it does is it
shows that in the scriptures it is
Yahweh who is the most high God and it
is that being that stands in the father
relation to Jesus. Okay. That's what is
explicitly stated in the scriptures. All
right. So, can you go to Genesis 31 for
me?
Uh sure.
I hope that what's going to follow is
you helping me to understand how you
avoid the conclusion not turning the
Bible back on me.
>> I already told you how. Uh but you just
cuz you're saying like you're not
accepting it, it doesn't mean that we
can't. Let's Let's go to the to the
scriptures Sure.
>> by your syllogism you assume that only
the father is identified as Yahweh.
So. No, if I could just point this out
one more time.
>> I'm going to show I'm going to show you
that Yahweh is not univocal. You think
it is.
Okay, we can talk about that. But if I
could just point something out real
quick.
I'm not assuming that Yahweh is only
uni- unipersonal in this syllogism. This
syllogism
>> are.
No, because as I pointed out to you in
eight and nine, do you remember on the
screen where I had eight and nine? If
you define Yahweh as multipersonal, what
happens if you do that? If you If you
identify that Yahweh is multipersonal,
then each distinct person can be
identified as Yahweh and Yahweh because
Yahweh is not univocal, depending on the
context it determines how you're using
Yahweh. So, your your conclusions in
your syllogism doesn't work. Well, well
I haven't seen how you would actually
avoid it by reference to the conclu- to
the conclusion that you made.
>> So then let's So let's stop playing
games and let's go to the scripture and
see if your syllogism stands. Fair
enough?
Uh absolutely. If you can show me in the
scriptures where for example like the
verses that I referenced
that I referenced how they're
>> Go to Genesis 31, brother.
Yeah, we can go to Genesis 31. By the
way, which uh verse do you want to do
real quick? You can start at uh you can
read verse 11 or 13. Okay, verse Genesis
31 and 11. I'm happy to discuss Genesis
31 with you. But I want to point
something out here real quick before we
do. Premise one and two
are explicit biblical statements that
state that Yahweh is the most high God
and that Jesus is the son of Yahweh.
Regardless of how many persons you think
Yahweh is.
>> just Did you just see what you just did
there?
Uh tell me what you think I did.
I'm And I'm going to tell you what you
did. Now I would just simply I think I'm
going to tell you what you actually did.
You're using Yahweh again univocally.
You're doing it again. I don't think
that you you don't even notice that
you're doing it.
>> Tell Tell me how you interpret those
statements to to to help me understand
the difference.
>> So you you are thinking that Yahweh only
is used for the Father based on Let me
say
I don't I'm not claiming that.
>> Is Yahweh used for anyone else other
than the Father?
Okay, you are Let me Let me Let me point
this out.
>> Just If you can answer that, please. Is
does Is Yahweh
>> is given to other beings than just the
Father, yes. Uh Who is it given to? Uh
for example, it was given to an the
angel of Yahweh. I believe that it was
given to the son of of Yahweh. Um but my
point is not
You're misunderstanding me. If I could
point this out, God logic.
>> So you even you acknowledge that multi-
that there's multiple persons who are
identified as Yahweh.
Uh multiple persons are identified with
Yahweh, yes. There multiple beings are
given the name Yahweh. But if I You're
misunderstanding me. I My argument
Nothing about my argument assumes that
Yahweh is unipersonal. You You don't
You're not getting it. If I could just
point this out one more
>> Is Yah- Is Yahweh unipersonal to you?
I personally that, but nothing about the
syllogism assumes this. Let me point
this out one more time, please. No,
Brickley. I'm tired of you repeating the
same thing, respectfully. I want to get
to the heart of your argument and your
belief. So, with you believing that
Yahweh, even the name Yahweh
You say Yahweh is the most high God.
That's not me saying that. Right. The
scripture says that. I agree with that.
>> Correct. Yahweh also says that. Yahweh
is the most high. Yahweh is the most
high God. Is Is Jesus identified as
Yahweh?
No, he's identified with Yahweh in the
sense that Yahweh gave him his name is
in terms of his authority, his divine
nature, etc. But, he's not the He's not
identical to his own father, no.
>> That's not what I asked if he's
identical to his father. Is he
identified as Yahweh, yes or no?
>> Not as, with.
Okay, so he's not identified as Yahweh.
So, he's not called Yahweh, right? So, I
I disagree with the the supposition in
premise five in my argument. I
personally disagree with it. But, what I
want to point out is there's a
difference between what I personally
agree agree with and what the argument
seems to conclude on the basis of a
plain reading of those premises. And I'm
asking you, how do you avoid it? Is Is
Jesus called Yahweh or not?
Um he's not called Yahweh. What what do
you mean by that?
Is there anybody
other than the Father
who is called Yahweh, identified as
Yahweh?
Identified with Yahweh by being given
his name, yeah.
>> me let let me say it again. Let me let
me say it again. No, identified as
Yahweh.
>> Because
because
Okay, thank you. Thank you. I just I I
said it repeatedly.
>> Okay, thank you. No, well no, what you
did was you you switched it like I was
asking a different question. You
switched it saying you identified with
Yahweh. That's not what I'm asking. I
asked if he was identified as Yahweh,
and you just finally answered it and
said no. Thank you.
>> no. Okay, thank you.
>> No, I didn't just finally. I answered it
before. All right, so all right. I got
you. So, only the Father is identified
as Yahweh. He's the only one who called
Yahweh. Got it. Now, go to Genesis 31
>> That's my personal belief. Good. Go to
Genesis 31.
So, okay. I'm happy to discuss this with
you, but I want to point out one more
time
>> now, brother. Now, now, now,
now, now, please.
>> Now, please. Now, please. Sure. Genesis
31. I I endo- I indulged your syllogism.
I let you go over it eight eight to 10
times. Now, indulge me. Let's get into
the heart of the argument. Genesis 31.
Yeah, we can discuss Genesis 31. Let's
go. What do you want me to read? Can you
read verses 11 to 13? Sure. Then the
angel of God said to me in the dream,
"Jacob." And I said, By the way, I'm
reading from the NRSVue. That's just the
standard translation I read.
"Here I am." And he said, "Look up and
see that all the goats that leap on the
flock are striped, speckled, and
modeled, for I have seen all that Laban
is doing to you. I am the God of Bethel,
where you anointed a pillar and made a
vow to me. Now, leave this land at once
and return to the land of your birth."
Okay. So, can we be honest with the text
and acknowledge that the angel of God
claims to be the God of Bethel, who
Jacob made a vow to?
Uh I wouldn't say that. I would I would
say that the angel of God is speaking
for God. All right. So, this is what I
need you to do for me. I need you to
show me that in the text. Show me where
the angel of God speaks for God, maybe
saying, "Thus says the Lord." or "This
is what the Lord says." or does the
angel just speak
uh first person by himself? So, can you
show me where it says "Thus says the
Lord" or just something along those
lines? It doesn't say "Thus says the
Lord." Okay. So, does it say anywhere
that the angel is speaking on behalf of
somebody else? Uh yes, when it says "The
angel of God said to me." that means
that it's the angel from God, who's
speaking for God.
>> Well, well, hold on. I understand it's
the angel from God. I get that. Where
does it say that he's speaking for God?
Cuz usually when we see the angel
speaking for God, he'll say he'll say,
uh "This is what the Lord says." That's
what they say.
>> So, here's my perspective. The answer to
your question is it's literally in the
name. The name is messenger of God,
meaning one who's bringing a message
from God.
Is
What What's a prophet?
A prophet is a human who brings a
message from God. Okay.
When a prophet speaks, does that mean
that he's that he's speaking the words
of God?
Absolutely. Every time?
I mean if he is speaking a message from
God, he's a prophet and he would be
speaking the message of God. I'm not
saying every word that any prophet ever
said is from God. How do you know the
difference?
Well, we know of course in this in the
scriptures that we have that the the
words from the prophets that are
identified as such are from God.
How do you know the difference when
let's say Moses is saying something from
God and saying something of himself?
>> [snorts]
>> So, if if what if what you're trying to
say is that there must be a thus saith
the Lord, then you could say that, but I
think that's incorrect. Okay, so how do
you know the difference?
Well, for example, if you know God is
speaking versus an angel of God
speaking, it would say God said versus
the angel of God said.
So, my question is this. Because the
angel is the messenger of God.
>> Hold on. When Moses speaks or a prophet
speaks, how do you know that when they
speak it's what they what it's what God
is saying and not themselves?
How do you know How do you make that
distinction?
Well, when a messenger of God such as a
prophet because a prophet is an another
kind of messenger.
>> Yeah, he's also
>> When a messenger of God speaks for God,
regardless of whether they say thus
saith the Lord or they just give a word,
it's them speaking for God. Uh my
brother,
stop telling me that the prophet speaks
for God. We already know that. My
question to you is very simple. I'm
asking it again.
>> Yeah, you you asked how you know the
difference.
>> How do you know the difference from when
the messenger is speaking for God and a
messenger is just speaking on his own?
Contextual clues. Sometimes there will
be
There will be things like thus saith the
Lord. Sometimes, not always. All right.
So, when there's not a "Thus saith the
demonstrations of of their power.
>> so when there's not a "Thus saith the
Lord,"
how do you know when a messenger is
speaking for God
or speaking of themself, if there's no
"Thus saith the Lord"? A messenger isn't
Look, in the context of what we're
discussing here in Genesis 31 with the
messenger of God,
the messenger of God would not be such
if they weren't speaking the words of
God.
>> Your assumption No, it's not an
assumption. It's in the name.
>> Is Moses still the messenger of God when
he doesn't speak for God?
No.
Oh, so there's a time when Moses is the
messenger of God and where he stops
being the messenger of God? No, I'm not
saying that. I'm saying by definition,
if he's not speaking for God
>> gosh. If he's not speaking for God, then
he's not a messenger for God. Okay,
let's do this again. I hope that you're
catching what you're saying.
Is there is there a time
when when after the after the burning
bush experience, was there ever a time
where Moses was not the messenger of
God?
Uh you know, like when he was talking to
his wife in the tent, for example, sure.
Did he stop being the messenger of God,
though?
He wasn't giving a message from God in
that moment.
>> But did he stop being the messenger of
God?
So So, um
first of all, I'm not aware um
I'm actually not clear on what the
primary point you're trying to make is.
Could you just make it for me so we can
maybe move forward? Nope.
Okay. I think you're smart enough to
catch it. And I don't mean that
specifically.
>> I've tried to respond to you and give
you my perspective, and I'm not seeing
how we're making any progress.
>> been you've been dodging. You've been
dodging. That's what you've been doing.
I'm I'm answering directly. What have I
dodged? What question have I dodged? The
question I just asked. Which one? Did he
stop being a messenger?
>> Yes. Yeah, did he
>> He's not giving a message from Mount
Sinai to his wife in the tent. No.
That's not what I asked.
He's still the messenger of God, of
course.
>> Thank you. So, even though there's times
where Moses speaks on his own and has
his own little life and has his own
little conversations, that doesn't mean
he's not the messenger of God even in
that moment. In general, yes. So So So
watch this. So a designation does not
automatically mean that whenever that
person is speaking, that means that
they're speaking on behalf of God. Just
like the angel of the Lord, he's the
angel of the Lord regardless, correct?
In a In general.
Uh Well, you seem to be assuming that
there's like a singular figure named the
angel of of the Lord. I think there's
multiple figures. I mean, we could we
could discuss that.
>> I'm talking about in general. An angel
of the Lord is an angel of the Lord
regardless as if
if they're speaking on his behalf or
not. They're the angel of the Lord in
general, right? Well, in general unless
they start speaking not on his behalf
like the angel in the garden for
example. Okay, so for So for example,
you just you're making a distinction. So
if if if an angel stopped speaking on
God's behalf
and said something on his own behalf.
But let's say it doesn't necessarily
contradict what God says. It doesn't
contradict or go against God, but God
didn't tell him to say this. He doesn't
say thus says the Lord. Is he no longer
an Is he Is he no longer an angel of the
Lord?
Um I think there's points um where, you
know, God for example in Cuz
a couple things. First of all, we're
kind of conflating prophets and angels.
And there's a sense
>> Wait It's a messenger. They're both
messengers.
>> They're they're both Yeah, they're both
messengers of of Yahweh, exactly. Um but
I think that we're talking in this text
about in Genesis 31 specifically about a
an angelic being per se. But what I want
to point out is that there's places in
the prophets when they talk about um uh
ministers of or messengers of Yahweh who
lose that status because of judgment
because they started to, like you said,
speak for themself. But in Genesis 31
>> No, it's not because they started to
speak for themselves. It's because they
directly went against God and rebelled.
>> Yeah, yeah, right. They started to They
started to disagree with or they started
to speak words that weren't from God. Um
but what I want to point
>> Hold on. Hold on. No, no. No. Let's do
this again because you're try You're
It's It's almost like you think that I'm
dumb that I won't catch what you do.
Brother, I'm Just give me more credit
than this, man. Give me Give me a little
bit more credit. You're not that slick,
at least not with me. You're not not
with me.
>> What What's the slickness happening
here?
>> It's not that that that that they didn't
speak the words of God. It's that they
spoke against God and rebelled against
him, correct?
>> That's what I just said. No, it's not.
There's two different things. Not
speaking for God and rebelling against
God are two different things. Can we
agree?
If God sends you to speak a word and you
rebel against God,
>> Can we agree? Uh
In general, but if God speaks you to
Thank you. So here's So here's
So here's
Very good. Now, did Did Jonah stop being
the messenger of God?
When he wasn't given a message, yes.
So So Jonah was in the boat. So So Jonah
in the boat was not a messenger of God?
Was he delivering the message God gave
him to deliver? No.
>> Was he designated a messenger of God?
>> He was still called to be one, but he
wasn't giving the message.
>> Okay. So when you have messengers and
you have a messenger of God, they have
this title and this designation in
general, even if they're not speaking on
behalf of God and they're speaking in
their own conversations, their own
relationships, Mhm.
>> they are still the messenger of God,
regardless, correct? Um I guess in
general, sure. What's the point with
regard to Genesis 31 or anything we're
talking about?
>> Well, well, you're about to see. All
right.
>> So therefore, simply having the title
messenger of God, cuz that's the title
here in Genesis 31, messenger of God,
angel of the Lord, angel of God,
messenger of God, that is a title that
that person has and that that person
operates in general.
That's who that's That's the job they
have, correct?
>> Yeah, that's their function. They're the
messenger of God.
>> Right. Now,
>> Yes. so
when a per- when a messenger of God
speaks on God's behalf,
contextual clues like "Thus says the
Lord" gives you that indication.
This is what the Lord says.
>> Can I Can I Can I
>> God gave you a revelation to say this.
Can I ask you a question?
>> because Hold on. Just because he's
designated angel of God, messenger of
God, does not mean that every word that
that the words coming from his mouth is
thus says the Lord, correct?
Uh
when we're reading a text like Genesis
31, I would not agree with that. Of
course, the passage starts with saying
the angel of the Lord said. Of course,
this is a message from God. Why would we
think otherwise? Who's speaking?
The messenger of God. Hence, it's a
message from God.
>> so the Oh, so God Oh, I see. So it's not
the angel speaking.
It's God speaking, right? Not the angel.
>> Through the messenger cuz it's his
message, yes.
>> where it says that. In the name, the
messenger of God. Thanks Thanks for
coming, Brickley. I appreciate you.
>> You're welcome.
Absolutely dishonest heretic.
>> [clears throat]
>> Dishonest heretic.
Please don't come back here, bro.
Just contradicted yourself over and over
and over again.
Yeah, no, it doesn't say that in the
scripture, but that's what we assume in
the name. Okay, so when is Moses the
messenger of God? Yes. Does every word
that come out of Moses' mouth the word
of God? Oh, no, he not when he's talking
to his wife. Oh.
So just because you're designated the
word the messenger of God, doesn't mean
every word comes out of your mouth is
thus says the Lord? Uh it's it's
speaking on behalf of God, I mean.
Idiots.
My goodness.